hi everyone my name is Qi Liu I'm a
partner at the Y Combinator I'm also
working on YC China today I'm very very
pleased to have the opportunity to speak
to Cindy me the founder and the CEO of
WebKit as many of the YC community in
the u.s. or China no lip kid has been a
tremendous entrepreneur ship success and
Cindy credit to your success you more
and more become a role model for many
entrepreneurs today I have the
opportunity I want to go through a list
of questions hopefully we can share out
of your insights
what learning you had over the years
that can prove to be a very calm very
valuable for many other young generation
entrepreneurs so let me start with sort
of your early phase upbringing because
as we look at the many entrepreneurs
motivation passion our long-term drive
was something is often a key success
factors can you show us where you grew
up
in particular what was like when you had
to move a video is at age of age of 14 I
believe moving to a different province
in a start new school what was the
experience like and how that that impact
you sure absolutely well first I'd like
to start by thanking UT for doing this
interview and then congratulations also
on funky and launching YC China thank
you this is really exciting for many
young entrepreneurs and tech people
because you're the role model for
everyone
for connecting the world and make it a
better place and making these companies
global from day one so thank you so much
for absolutely event I'm really looking
forward to our discussion so if her to
your question on the story of my
operating and growing up I was born in a
little Club
precisely so it was John taco city where
the Winter Olympic Games will be hot yes
but the reason I believed so much in
lifelong learning is because I moved
from John's alcohol to Harvey
hello John province when I was 40 years
old and in my math class my teacher
hated me she thought I was the most to
be a student on the planet she just just
doesn't believe I I can learn so I lost
confidence II in learning when when I
was a little kid and I thought you know
school probably is not the right place
for me and I should leave so I dropped
out of high school when I was in the
11th grade but nevertheless I was very
lucky because I studied children young
kids English when I was 15 years old a
part time so teach me has been my
passion and and learning has been the
motivation that drives me all these
years and then through teaching young
kids I learned that every child is so
curious and we should help them build
the connection to the world of the best
teachers and content and learning
experience and then they can imagine and
explore and then three experience of
being an English tutor I figured
learning is also so important for the
tutor or teacher herself because if only
if you learn more you can then teach
better and then creates this lifelong
learn learning mission for all the kids
so that we can learn better that was
very interesting
so while your shared was so the early
phase of experience motivated also
shaped the spirit for you to become a
educator in many ways to promote
learning but the interesting aspect for
me is learning and English and also
learning blender was entrepreneurship
entrepreneurism so can you also tell us
more about that specs for example I
believe you start learning English when
you
were 13 and you mentioned that you start
tutoring other kids English when you
were around 15 yeah and there's another
very very very interesting aspects you
actually co-founded and English training
school when you were at 17 with your
uncle believenot who is there with your
uncle so tell us more about that and how
those sort of bring together shape up
söderling step instill spirit in you as
an educator and also a entrepreneur sure
absolutely
so when we moved to Beijing it was a
very lean startup experience
we rented a one class room in the middle
of nowhere
now today by the third room Road but by
then it was a very rural area in the
city so we went and find students by the
elementary school that they go to and
then sent fliers to there from parish
and then say hey common and learn with
us and you don't have to pay and you get
a gift and if you like it they can stay
and continue to learn with us and then
the the lessons that I learned from
those early early days is very important
because it helps really filled up the
understanding of the students the
parents and then to be entrepreneur or
to fund the person and I think there are
so many things one needs to to do well
for example how do we hire the right
people how do we how do we make sure we
have the best culture how do we build
our customer base one by one and make
sure everyone is happy and successful
so I was the chief Aaron officer but
really all the errands right I was I was
driving card I need to pick up the other
teachers yeah from like 20 kilometres
away in Hangzhou and then when when
everyone goes to bed I need to continue
to a little more and to prepare for the
next day so by running all the errands I
think just taught me so many things but
then
by being so close to the customers
namely our students I I got the
privilege to understand much more on
what every child want and what every
parent want so I think those
understanding really shaped the way that
what I think about learning or education
and and and then when I got the chance
to build the second business a VIP kid
business
I then really understand depreciates
with more on how difficult it is to
build something from the scratch and
then what are the mistake not to make
and and how do how to do better that was
a terrific sort of experience you went
to running odd errands that they're
learning about the students what they
need also the parents because education
email is the users are not a buyers the
parents actually what page is the
parents so understanding both students
and parents are super important
well you just a touch about so naturally
let me switch to the next key cell area
topic I'm gonna also I seen the a list
of questions about how you stop
replicating your second business and
initially why you saw the opportunity
that many others perhaps at the same
time didn't see in particular English
learning market when you started was
already very competitive market there's
a lot of players in that space in China
and other people always say it's a hyper
competitive a very very aggressive what
you see as a unique opportunity that you
latch on to and how you convince
yourself and your teams that you can win
in this very hyper competitive
environment that's a great question
so when we started VIP kid back in 2013
the market was competitive be the market
size is about fifteen billion US dollars
parents spending every year and then
Chinese parents value education as
investments so from around 15% of our
household income goes to south
education 50% for all sort Oh compared
to 2% in the u.s. that's in some ways
the the culture in the tradition for it
had so much anise specific but because
it is absolute to the Chinese parents
value education and the willing to
invest that's great to know so it's 50%
of household income they're willing to
spend versus 2% United States that's
terrific and and then although it's a
competitive market but there are still a
lot of pain points yet to be solved for
the parents so how do win the the pain
points that I see from by then 15 years
of being the classroom and and being
close to the students and parents are a
few one is we don't really have good
English teachers that are out of China
today so there are only 27,000 North
American teachers national-wide and and
the number is so little compared to our
vast number of students there are 17
million new babies born every year and
there there's about a million elementary
school kids only in Beijing yeah and
today VIP kid has more than 16,000
teachers yes it's almost three times
over supply so supply has been a huge
challenge and you know what parent want
is a good teacher and I think a teacher
can make or break her students learning
curiosity and in sports that lifelong
learning spirit so it's really critical
to have the best teachers and then even
if the teachers are you in China it's
mostly very young like people spending a
couple years in China they're not really
teachers so the teachers where it will
do find are the best kid health
educators in the u.s. coming from all
different states Texas is our largest
teacher / - we really love our teachers
and they're the reason that that's why
so teacher supply but secondly is the
the content of our learning students are
still learning
curriculums from many many years ago and
it stays unchanging but we will have
technology like all those pads and and
mobile devices devices for children it's
much more engaging if they are able to
explore and for example read the online
learning library and and they have the
content to to get access to instead of
just a whole set of York yeah so the
content has also been a challenge in the
traditional like service providing that
parents can that get access to
and lastly talking about language
learning if one has spent 15 minutes a
day to learn the language it's much more
effective than 15 minutes times 7 you're
putting to a 2 hour weekend class yeah
because more frequency house memorizing
yes better and utilizing the language
and in a much more effective way as a
tool so those are the pain points that
parents feel in terms of quality and
lastly parents today are so tired of
bringing their children - children
classes in the weekend it's a more like
a challenging job than their data of you
they they have no free time of their own
so parents would prefer if children can
learn from home and they can probably do
yoga at the center so all these pain
points we've been rethinking how can we
reimagine children's English language
learning so we can bring more value to
the kids probably 10 times better
so so that's why I VIP kid launched by
the idea that we want to find the best
teachers build this global classroom
where we connect cultures and sparks the
lifelong learning spirit for the kids
yeah so the product itself by what
parents believed in and word comment on
is at least five times better if not ten
times compared to the existing products
and services this is terrific Cindy let
me summarize a few key things that I
move to next questions sort of right
conduct to while you're describing
essentially you through your
experience you identify a set of
opportunity unique links a woman's
demand essentially it particularly the
Chinese parents the China's traditional
value learning education willing to
spend that's the demand is there and
it's growing the second is you identify
opportunity etcetera to use the internet
to expand the supply because without the
internet you actually a set of teachers
in the United States won't be necessary
become a surprise but technology enable
you to have that unique insight to say I
can bring a lot more supply in another
different way that's a second a very big
insight sir is sort of the content and
devices that available can be more
engaging and the forces the product form
you sort of tuned to the language
learning itself moving to a smaller set
of chunks making it much easier as we
said five times better than alternative
for that's terrific settling site that
you've identified and then my question
to you is almost every star founders
will grapple with which is the classical
Prada market fit essentially you
identify a market order that you see the
supply the demand you have the
opportunity to bring them together but
ultimately you still have a product that
fits the market demand you already
elaborate quite a bit about the some
aspects of product content device short
duration continues learning lifelong
learning but in the early days of VIP
kit as a founder I'm curious do you have
a set of measurement metrics or key
success factors that you keep measuring
comparing and say this will help me to
find the problem market fit and keep
improving the product on all those
metrics and then when do you feel like I
already find it this is the products in
a way so help us sort walk through this
I think that would be super helpful for
a lot of funders that are sort of
initially starting going through this
phase and they try to learn what the
insight you can share with them how to
find the problem of if it actually
that's that's a we it took us a year and
a half okay to on the you'd have yeah
that part up market
it's a very long time yeah we had a few
matrix that are still very important to
us today what kind of measures yeah yeah
so those are like efficiency and
effectiveness and engagement of our
students and that's essentially what
believed to be the user value of the
product we created so for efficacy we
would be measuring students units
assessments of scores so of course
testicles right so those are evaluations
conducted by our teachers livestreaming
first and also the practice Kurtis are
these standard or like that what sort of
tests are you similar to schools how
they test English or you you meant
something so similar to schools but we
do build our curriculum content based on
our scope and sequence and the knowledge
that we need students to learn and the
skills you need to master so based on
those scope and sequence we've develop
our content so it's really critical for
us to go back and then check and then
see well how does she learn how does a
student project and then is everything
very efficacious so it's really
important to have that and and secondly
on on the effectiveness we would then be
measuring of all the time that is
consumed on the on the platform how much
progress has this child made and then
lastly on engagement and what a how well
is a student rating the class and what
are the feedback from the parents and
theirs does he keep coming back and take
classes your reader and then it does
this the parent referred our program to
other parents what is NPS score so those
are the very basic and fundamental
matrix that we will look at and when we
evaluate the product market fit so by
the fruit first year and a half what we
did in words of a few steps one is we we
started with actually for students mm-hm
I see because we can't not find the
fifth so why should you
for the fifth year so that's an MVP
rival party and salivation ventures dr.
carefully or they found it I say [ __ ]
they had to help us find the first three
places if I stir you find another one oh
that one was a friend as well my
co-founder Jesse's I see okay so it was
a Lucy its CEO of crystal and lovely I
see it's it's very hard to persuade even
the four to start to learn with the
program but but then later on gradually
every month we would have additional ten
students so it makes it almost 200 by
March 2015 and then throughout this
whole experience we've iterated our
content and technology platform a cup of
two times our radar stream because it's
critical to we only have a limited
resources as all the like every
entrepreneur in the very early there is
your startup teams and so we had a
handful of like in content developers in
the handful of engineers so where we
spend those resources matter the most
and then by iterating three times three
versions of our content and two versions
of our like online learning platform we
found the most important tools or the
ways that we need to build for our
students and similarly on the teacher
site we also make sure that our teachers
are happy with the schedule they find a
convenient to teach they have the
essential tools that they need and they
have the content that is very well
designed by our team so it's also a part
of market fit for the supplier as well
you have to do both sides
where does your marketplace right we're
double side marketplace we have to do
both but we I think we have more
responsibilities in double sided
marketplace we need to guarantee the
quality the serve of the whole
experience for both students and
teachers and their success are what we
believe to be the most important
so by piloting the program with 20
teachers and 200 students in the first
year and a half when everyone was like
2014 it was the year
where everyone celebrates
entrepreneurship and grow like funding
the company every day we chose to you
know really lock ourselves in a little
room and figure out all these
fundamental challenges and an important
part of marketing questions terrific so
there's a lot of things I will actually
have a couple of follow-up questions
based on what you described but see the
why you should is in many ways sort of
YC also advocates for essentially it's
always about build something users or
customer wall can be a very humble
beginning your case for kids for kids
and you start teaching but once you find
life it will grow right so at some point
from what you described sort of the key
markers of initial milestone will be 20
teachers 200 students and you have two
iterations or platforms through
iteration content that in many ways
showcase you find something I think this
is a terrific story it's motivating for
many others startups don't be so
discouraged I all want I have only have
one users or two users
any big enterprise the or star is small
in your case it's just a terrific that
you start with
how about beginning sound of a shimmer
to give you three students you'll find
another one that's that's awesome story
so what I will have to learn a few
questions I think sort of classic before
a lot of founders gosu one is the
business model the revenue models
because ultimately we operate a market
you need to make it a business wise it
does income otherwise you won't sustain
so how do you essentially get to the
point whereby the key segment of people
which is the parents are I believe
assume this is the case and they are
wanting to say ok this is it this is
something good and my kids are learning
good stuff I wanted to fake pay for how
are you so find the business model and
making sure that that this business
model is viable and it can provide a
sustained growth for an enterprise so
can you share with us back to experience
sure that the business development side
yes so the for business model we
believed
we believe that it's essential to bring
value to both sides of that market the
students and parents and the teachers so
for the students and parents the value
in the business model is we have lowered
significantly the one-on-one learning
experience the cost for the pounder by
more than 50% 50% of used to pay about
600 are be worth less than hundred US
dollar to to find a one-on-one teacher
and as we talk about they're only 27,000
so good luck finding what you can it's
very difficult that you can and then
it's literally impossible also to find a
teacher and have her come to your house
every day for half an hour because the
commutes will be two hours for that half
hour class and you've got a paper
so essentially parents find it if they
only pay for a small class tuition for
one on my experience they have multiple
times of value created and also on top
of that 60 50 to 60 percent less than
they had to pay for one on one offline
so they're paying about like $40 per
hour of the one-on-one learning so it's
and the teacher are really amazing
they're they're five times better than
what they can find in China so if you
multiply those values you probably see a
ten-time yes yes the value created for
our parents and students and also
tutored written love it because they
previously they cannot find you you
don't you can never choose your teacher
you can't let me go to a trinny like
Institute and there is a teacher for you
you sign up you alone and now it's very
personalized we can prepare the most
suitable engaging and motivating teacher
for this child out of our 60,000 teacher
so all these are value created for for
students parents and for teachers
similarly if you look up on payscale.com
you then find teachers get paid 16 US
dollar
per hour of their tutoring service I see
and then you got a commute as well half
an hour one way two hours you get paid
16 oh of course not in New York or San
Francisco where parents pay Hilary a lot
of money for 4's SATs or a CTS but
generally we're talking about like the
few million k12 teachers and English
language teachers national whites in the
US or Canada so the value for teachers
then is they are willing to teach with
global student bodies but unless they
move to China or Asia or like Japan they
can't do this and and also teachers many
of teachers are female and then also
when they have children they become stay
home moms for fulfill yrs that's a
really great the teachers are doing this
for the family but at the same time
teachers need to supplement families
income and you know if you are in Salt
Lake City in Utah what are the options
as a teacher to make those supplemental
income
so then the epic it brings value to our
teachers in a way that we pay our
teachers about 20 US dollar per an hour
we make sure they don't have to commute
they can't even stay home and and teach
in the early morning and then spend the
whole day with a kid with a family so
there we have a very very strong teacher
community teachers are connected with
each other and I you see the 30,000 B
YouTube videos that teachers are created
Facebook community we have teacher
conferences so all these value add we
put together our event that it created
for our teachers so we want to make sure
that we are here to facilitate the
communication the culture connection
they're learning and everyone is
successful and there becomes then the
VIP hit business model gotcha gotcha
it's terrific so essentially fundamental
you focus on real value creation on both
sides and then economic economic model
becomes very natural and sustainable so
I have related questions which is lot of
startups always need to be focused on
which is you mentioned iteration because
ultimately build a long term successful
businesses there will be things you have
to
and appears to you are learning what
sort of iteration you mentioned you know
iteration on content iteration platforms
what sort of things you tried that
didn't work sort of the siene learnings
offer you learn a lot more by trying
something didn't work and then you
captured a learning move on to a new
self expand others important the
learning lesson you can share with the
other startups funders I've got two
lessons that I learned that are a very
deep memory for me so one is we try to
build too much for the technology plus
where we started from
it's common mistake you would always
imagine well this we perfect yeah yeah
this and that and that and then a
beautiful ooh prints that are so
impressive to everyone but then we need
to aren't we have to understand there
are limited resources so that we we did
spend like three months try to build
this in the second half year of 2014 and
then we found it did it didn't work here
you should focus on what's most seen in
and then we reorganized our resources I
just launched something formally March
2015
otherwise we'll probably won't be able
to launch anything right there and the
funny fact is that of the bull prints we
built by then
four years ago some of the work we
haven't even finished today so it's not
a three months job yeah that's a
probably tenure dub that we've printed
and second thing was we were not ready
for growth but one of the key opinion
leaders one of the student parents she
owns a weeble blog and she posted got a
big leaf day right and she posted on on
we book so about 2000
apparent sign up for the day and we took
us three months to call them back
actually so we we probably should be
thinking about oh we've been building
the part of market failure it takes a
lot long time but what if in the middle
of the the time
like something exploded and there you've
got to be ready for this but because
it's negative a customer satisfaction if
they didn't get respond along the way No
so the solution we had was a everyone
becomes a customer service person and
our engineers really hated it when they
are asked that's why he did that
that's terrific yeah but our engineer
said I didn't want to talk to people
that's why I become an engineer my
parents it's really difficult so we but
we didn't manage to make sure 2,000
customers get addressed and responded
and connected in the time span of three
months but there were a lot of
unsatisfactory voice people say are you
guys for real where are you you know but
you're calling me what's wrong with you
yeah yeah that's awesome only so now B
let me see any sort of a move one step
up obviously looking back you have a
sort of early beginning now it's very
clear lipcott is going through
tremendous school just walking up stairs
this morning going through our building
it's it's very impressive now you have a
building almost 10,000 employees with
massive set of grosses at the courts
always about product my understanding is
your product recently goes through a lot
of expansion for example you are getting
into meandering learning and essentially
moving from English to another language
in some ways the market sort of reversed
the learner will be maybe in North
America the teacher will be in China
sold it's a swap if you want then the
original product and also you have
expand your English learning product
from some of the classic one one into
one four and you also expand the range
of students from all the way from sort
of zero how imagine a zero young kids
learning to 18 years old how you
envision how sort of strategize pick
these products missions and how those
new product initiations initiatives come
together to catalyze the next phase of
growth for replicate so the theme of
obvious your potted services we both are
common theme is to build a global
classroom global classroom okay that is
shared by many many teachers and
students this theme tie everything but
with amazing content that is
personalized and also connect cultures
and in sparks this lifelong learning for
everyone so so then comes the the
one-on-one VIP cake and then we have se
BC are one of many 104 model and and
then we have mentoring learning and all
the other curricula set so the we follow
the demand of the parents and students
who work with and we believed that by
building this global classroom we then
had a great chance to personalize
learning for the kids with theta
technology and and also we would my
dream and go as a tutor a teacher myself
is to empower our teachers better by
beauty more intelligent tools in
assistance like functions so that our
teachers job can become much easier in
the days to come actually can make more
income and then be happier gotcha
so this is super helpful it's
essentially there's cohesive singing of
global massively expanding
classroom that's personalized and
technology and data can enable both
sides and owner to them better that
teachers to be able to teach better so
in that context content always seem to
play a important role my understanding
is replicate is also so renowned a set
of initiative to expand the content for
example you had a recent partnership
with I believe last scholastic that
including sort of premier contact Harry
Potter's and also was houghton mifflin
harcourt and asked for University and we
could these are small English content
and then speaking of Mandarin learning
what do you think will be sort of the
marquee catalyst Chinese content that
can help the manner of learning so I
occurs to see how you envision the
content aspects of expanding of your
product portfolios okay
so similarly we also follow the needs
and demands of our our students and
parents so for the Harry Potter content
Scholastic partnership we also have the
a lot of reading library like readers
that we introduce to the platform so
that's based on the skill that we
believe to be very important reading for
our children of to have a global library
and we also work with our partners like
Alexa to measure children's more like
reading ability and then to to measure
how they've learned without major
critical together with a reading library
content and also for the Houghton
Mifflin Harcourt and our content we
reintroduced journeys and collections
which are the elementary school and high
school curriculum for American students
at school today to be accessible and
available for China's international
school students who's willing to later
on take a global like international
school path and then we partnered also
with SSAT oh ok ok so that we're we're
then able to provide our students with a
very exclusive opportunity to sign up
and to to take that assessment and also
a TOEFL primary TOEFL junior for young
kids as well as a third-party assessment
tool I see I see
ok so let me maybe take up conversation
into one more step which is the global
aspects it because earlier you mentioned
emphasizing anyways VIP kit the prior
roadmap and the long-term vision is
supposed to be a global classroom that's
personalized learning that's also fits
into the sort of the biggest themes that
we see particularly the y-component that
there is more global innovations new
startups they all tend to have
aspiration to be a global company and
the vindicating sound was very unique
your beginning is global because you
connect the supply demands throw a
global platforms can you share with us
with sort of your learning experience
how do you initially build sort of
global aspects from beginning from
what are the challenges that you had to
overcome by building global company
that's based in China absolutely
so I was at the first fungus forum yeah
two years ago yes last year and also
this year this year's are so good to
have you I accompanied her family the
community and then the the the topic
Anu gave me for the first year was a
global company from day one I see so it
was a very tasty topic and then I think
if you happy if it is able to make this
happen or for a few reasons
one is I think we believe that with our
teacher community we are global from day
one I personally interviewed and and
persuaded our first 20 teachers I see oh
the first one was extremely challenging
how actually how to do that do for at
United States are you thinking to do
remotely so I interviewed remotely I
said well I did spend three months
trying to find he just in the US I see
Oh before I found a VIP kid Portland
Oregon I see Los Angeles character did
you go to Texas I didn't go to class as
president I've seen New York I even went
to Toronto Canada to to fight teachers
so by spending 300 time I understand it
is extremely difficult for people to
come to China but if they were to allow
to work from home and you will be
something really beautiful for teachers
because every teacher wants to have like
Pao de Montaigne that the teacher the
helping exceed oh look the learning of
every child a student across the globe
by the Chinese say so the it's a value
that teachers want to teach work locally
and globally so the community is
essential for our global perspective
because the it's our entire supply side
and then our teachers coming from all
states and Texas is our largest state
yeah and all 50 states all 50 spicy and
for the Texas community we're very proud
of our second teacher conference
he's obvious Dallas Texas issues the
former first lady Laura Bush keynote
session she's been whole afternoon our
teachers feel so proud of the
acknowledged imprisoned by her and and
then Orlando is where we had our third
teacher conference the city named VIP
kid day day for the whole city yes only
eighth of September and it's a great
honor for teachers because they feel
that reason this contribution is so well
recognized by their better mayor and our
first very first teacher conference is
in Salt Lake City Utah
it's where teachers are so loving and
passionate we will have our fourth one
in Chicago next year so we just signed a
MoU with the city mayor of Chicago by
helping the underserved community in
Chicago to the case to learn Mandarin
and we'll be providing programs for free
are so this is the global community that
everyone cares so much about and the
value is it's tremendous yeah you're the
teachers and the local community so that
I think that's a very important reason
and secondly we have a global team from
day one as well and today we have a San
Francisco office we just launched a new
City office in on a whole wall street
actually 301 hoard and and our team's
interesting what that team does you
actually didn't realize you have a team
in San Francisco what I think does it
like a day-to-day do customer service or
product development what's their rope
I'm very curious to know that so it the
team is essentially about teacher
success okay so we have people mostly
San Francisco but we also have a Texas
Dallas as well and then we have team in
New York in and everywhere so the the
team are from organizations like Teach
for Teach for America um like at the
communities in the US people who's
worked in United Nations of those
Institute globally to help teachers be
successful so we we have people who
really
about teacher sickness and they are from
the local community that knows how to do
it and how to communicate with our
teachers and we've built a very
transparent service platform for our
teachers we have a coda hotel it's our
food oh right it's a post II system
where our teachers can send us tasks or
questions or tickets or anything that we
need to work on and we communicate very
proactively with our with our teacher
community you know and we have teachers
keeping in leaders you have formed all
those are Facebook groups are and
initiated local like events like
communities but those are some of the
worker facilitated by our teacher
success team that but everyone I really
love and admire our us T because they
are they constantly fly all different
stages also teacher event and make sure
teachers can have a great time yeah and
whenever there is something we need to
work on our tests they would be in the
teachers house the next day and be there
to make sure that they're successful I
think it's because we've got the right
people yeah that's perfect I think Tupi
success factors always the wonderful
community the other is the teams that's
on the ground here at state say and if I
may say the last one the last one I
think is where people in the yard
Beijing office are we really want to
make sure that we have a very good
communication and we cater for a
different time zone oftentimes six hours
lot of global relations what they
struggled it was the difficulties
building a global culture that that's
being very mindful about the other teams
it would be 16 hours away when we
scheduled meeting we don't want a
scheduled meeting when people have to
wake up or in the wee hours so how do
you I'm curious how do you sort of
cultivate that maybe that's what the
Beijing teams is very mindful about the
US team the US team is also when they
collaborate they really sort of think
for the other side make sure that we can
create a environment internally
yeah people do to work together to build
success for the global path so so
firstly we we make sure when we like
operate we have the most availability to
our teachers in this organization we set
up so if you think about how teachers
can't apply an interview with the IP kid
is 24 hours we might have a team that
work on night shift
access I still have a night shift to
team the value I think then very
naturally would impact on how the team
work together so I was asking the head
of my global business development team
and he said I have a morning call for
you a morning Thomas called not a
morning call the Margay 3m yeah and
because of the time differences and and
then you work with your partner center
but I think it's just the the the
culture is led by example yes if the
leadership teams would want to do this
and they would accommodate more to the
teams that are not in the the bigger
office I think it made much easier and
also we also have this concept of global
do headquarter idea so we want our
teachers to to to on to trust that so
teachers teachers sometimes would say
this is too good to be true
are you guys for real you're so far away
so we want teachers to understand that
with our American headquarter in San
Francisco office is there to make sure
we have teacher success and our team is
there it's so important and critical to
our future success and we're keeping
investing in the team now I said 30
people team were investing the team to
be or 200 people with tenure so we want
to make sure that the the team there has
more they can execute on and help the
teacher with so that we can build a
culture terrific so particularly that
one thing you mentioned Cindy the
cultures best to shape or most shaped by
leaders behavior that's true for so many
successful organizations maybe
switchgear to the last stretch on our
data this morning which is looking
forward to the lantern future the future
of Education particularly Cindy
in the context of a massive new wave of
technologies for example AI that will
give us so much more technological
abilities what is your big Lantern more
ambitious visions for the future
education because you already have a
very very strong vibrant platform
what's that vision with these new
technologies can you share with us
absolutely
so the the common theme there is for the
big global classroom that we were able
to build on the cloud two things one is
personalization the other is empowerment
so the idea for personalization is that
learning should be engaging and
effective and efficacious and fun but
then every child is so different yeah
so how can we find the most appropriate
in engaging motivating teachers for the
child and then how do we make sure there
is a personalized learning that's based
on the knowledge graph that we've paired
up the content like massive thank you
for readers and learning content and
both and everything and then also how do
we make sure that the way teachers
engage with the child is most focused on
how this child learns and then what are
the methodology the training we need to
give to teachers and then for the
empowerment especially I think for
teachers job it's been a very most
almost most challenging job on human
history but but then the the common
traits for good teachers are a very very
similar the passion for your students
though the love the understanding of
this child and then the real-time
interaction between the child and
teacher to motivate and to inspire so
how do we help our teachers feel the
more effective tool so that they would
have a AI tutor your teaching assistant
means to to help our teachers to do
their job better so our teachers can be
more effective
and they can get paid more they can be
happier with what they do and they can
make more impact because if they can
only teach one like teacher ten students
they can probably they don't teach a
hundred students even a thousand
students when we're able to empower our
teachers with technology terrific that's
a very powerful vision for the mountain
future
my fellow question to use India is
looking back looking forward yours very
very inspiring journey what are the the
key devices that you will have for
today's young generation entrepreneur
jet just thinking about studying or just
starting if there's one important piece
of device to them what that would be a
great question I mean think about this
but at the same time you I also ask you
a question on the technology piece sure
because I think you're you're the role
model for every like parents were packed
background and know want to be global
and I hope their children learn better
so I have caught two questions but you
will give you my essence but I would
make sure that you also give the
important oh well in the founders USB
he'll figure out your most important one
but I think my question to you is one is
how how should a engineer product
manager or anyone intact think about
education sector going forward because
traditionally is think like that matters
more it's a met medical like technology
matters more what are the opportunities
in education technology that every
parent if they're able to change the
world and make it better for for their
children going forward what should they
be thinking about for the sector and
also on the AI question what are the
things you believe to be the driving
force for the for the change for the
okay so I will share some what my
thoughts was the obvious caveat I think
these are from coming from my personal
observation but I'm not a domain expert
this is more observing from a macro
perspective and to project that into the
education space and in many ways seen
while you article earlier is in my view
is a very very expensive comprehensive
vision because you've adjusted the
learning side
the teaching side the platform the
personalization the knowledge graph that
connects everything so on top of that
here's a couple of things that for me
that's important the one is I think
ultimately technology should be able to
transform pretty much everything we do
as a society and the education is
perhaps among the most important to me
personally is always about education
medical services visit oh these are the
only two human professions that are
unique they make human better education
I perhaps will pay a little bit more
emphasize because if imagine every kids
or every adult can always learn more can
become wiser empowers and more knowledge
the world will be a much much better
place so they've made so many positive
things can come out of learning so
personally I taught actually briefly in
food a university provide went to
Carnegie Mellon and I always have this
sort of lingering passion for teaching
because it's fun meeting Potter's having
said that also sort of observed
education for the past couple thousand
years hasn't really changed that much
technology hasn't really make a massive
uplift or transformation yet to why you
haven't done in many ways is a
tremendous step forward what I think at
its core for the innovator seeing in the
air tech space you to think about is the
end to end concrete learning scenario
because technology is only a means to
survey and we cannot sort of put the
horse before the cart with technology
some focus on technology I think the
other way around I think we are all
better off thinking the learning the
teaching that completes Eliza let's say
for example early childhood what I
learned is so my own complete knowledge
a sixth grader United States learning
fraction mathematics is actually the
defining moment there would be the most
sort of leading indicators on these kids
intellectual development and there's a
lot of sort of
cutting-edge technologies including
bring scans to so analyze how a sixth
graders learn fractions and I was sort
of holding on at capri Solaris how do we
teach how do we really understand a
six-year-old
sixth graders lone fraction mathematics
and then use that to make sure that our
content our teachings our learning
experiences are truly transforming to
next level so that every kids will be
given much much better opportunities to
learn fraction mathematics and that
opens the door for them to whether they
want to be a artist whenever you want to
be a engineer they can all be better off
so our focus on salario and trying to
narrow in anything and say what
technology can do that's sort of one
piece of thoughts the other is on the
technological side them this is my
personal view a is massive we have a
precedent set of technological
capabilities for me I think we need to
understand what's the core essence of
aqua is behavior this is AI is about a
rapid efficient way of a quality
knowledge we can use sensors cameras
whatever senses to observe a phenomena
and use deep learning machine learning
some techniques to rapid rate is doing
to seven oranges this knowledge is power
as bacon said was knowledge we would
understand so I think with the early
cusp of understand fundamentally how
human law how kids learn language how I
adopted them a new programming language
or new manufacturing skills with the
very early cusp I think WebKit is a
powerful platform global platform with
additional technological capability you
will be able to get so much more
personalized data to figure out at the
early frontier how kids room language
I'm pretty sure you expand your part of
the map how let's say kids learn
artistic skills drawings
Dancing's or designing new machineries
you know the futures unlimited the key
is can we sober and technology with
passionate innovators like yourself and
then truly used opportunity in front
of us to make learning so much better
for everyone
I'm truly cover was that the world will
be a vastly better place in the four
decades to come
thank you that's so hot but mm Amos sort
of comments because I sort of often
fancy myself to be a teacher even though
I do taught at top for you as as a
teacher at the Florida University in the
future when there is opportunity I
certainly would be interested in in the
cotton why see China or why see overall
Cindy would love to explore future
opportunity we can collaborate helping
more innovators figure out new
technologies new way of teaching the
learnings and hopefully that can be
synergistic to WebKit as well that's
really exciting
thank you I think to echo what you said
learning science is a huge opportunity
here to lead to hope for kids and I
totally agree with you that we should
start from the scenario where a sixth
grade child learned those affections
very math and I apparently failed when I
was a sixth grade and the seventh grade
is where I had the most challenge
learning math and if the child can be
assistant and and hoped exactly the
technology sort of learning better it
just feels so much better foundation for
the future learning think I'm for the
great like visionary common can we come
back to sort of you our wisdom if you
can share it and if there's sort of one
piece of verbal people feedback or
advice to a young founders today yeah
what that would be okay so I think the
most important thing is always the most
apparent thing and it's always so hard
to stick to it every day even if you are
you think you believe in it and but then
I think you would need to check on your
actions your like agenda
schedule you need to see if you're
investing the most time on it so my
answer there is customer success so I
think full VIP kids the core of success
is
because parents teachers our colleagues
all 10,000 of them ultimately what we
want is student success the the young
minds being spark or to learn and
curious and the imagine and everything
it's the dream that everyone wants for
their own children is what everyone want
for like the hundred and thousands of
APK students and there are a lot of
challenges as we talk about a global
company the culture the the word
timezone the technology the day one
problem mark if it but then how does
everyone keep how do everyone work keep
working together go you through all the
challenges because they're always a lot
of them it's the common goal that we
want student success and then go to the
teacher success part is also important
that we can align on this and then like
i personally would fly 25 hours to be at
our teachers a conference in orlando
because i had to be you know another
business and after flying 25 hours tree
i went to the conference straight away
and i stood there for four hours so that
our teachers can take photos one-on-one
with me and then everyone shared with me
in three sentences their own story and
more than half are in tears and everyone
thinks maybe i think a platform because
they said to me make sure tell your team
it's they're diligent in answering all
the home like post questions and
communities made our success so that our
teacher said you know i'm a retired
teacher I broke my leg last year I can't
teach but I need the income so VIP kid
really helped me loving my kid and then
making an income another teacher said I
had breast cancer but I was pregnant I
work so much I cannot have a healthy
baby like VIP kid gave me the emotional
support the income opportunity and then
now here's my photo of my baby so I
think its customer student like success
future success that are so critical our
team are many of our wake-up calls are a
set of 10
customer phone calls from the previous
day some of us would do it I am on the
way to work seven am on the way to doing
on the on the in the gym were for me 60
30 a.m. to listen to all those customer
feedback and then eight motivates a team
greatly to go to work and solve nearby
challenges so I think the the thing is
very apparent but it's very difficult to
stick to it every day make sure that
everyone does it so I think the VIP kid
team bears in mind that our mission is
to inspire and empower and reach out for
the future it's it's such a challenging
goal because for the future already it's
a difficult topic and what we want for
the future for our children is a global
kid global citizen and then how do we
build up their 21st century skills and
how to build up this global competency
this is something that we really need to
European but inspire and empower itself
is also very challenging because it's
not just teach the children give them
the fish it's teach them how to face
issues make sure that they're inspired
to learn they wanna learn so all these
the admission and ambition we have
drives the team forward and I think as a
young entrepreneur it's very important
to to check on us every day and to to
figure out whether we're doing the right
thing
so was that Cindy it's truly inspiring
thank you very much for the wonderful
interview session today I on behalf of Y
Combinator's or community members very
much or a thank you for your time and
best wishes for continued success with
webkit it's inspiring journey thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
you